[Music]
okay everybody i am so so excited today
because i am joined by dina shihabi aka
melody from archive 81 which is out now
on netflix
everybody there is spoilers in this
interview for the show so make sure you
watch season one first and then come
back to this we'll be talking all about
those things dina how you doing today
i'm good i'm so excited to talk to you
yeah i i'm so thrilled to talk to you
it's so exciting um
i'm wondering too with this role you're
in was there ever any hesitation for you
taking on this part or did you know
right away you wanted a role like this
out of the gates
i knew i wanted it i read the script and
fell in love with the part and just
like willed it into existence that i got
it
um
and
then i got to set and i was like holy
[ __ ] i'm in pain and in distress for
eight episodes i was like
oh my god and it took a lot out of me um
and
and in that way it was like a huge
challenge but such an incredible
experience to go home every day after a
whole day of just feeling like you're
giving every part of you to something
and the script was so good and the
creatives like all the directors were
incredible the actors are incredible
our writers did such an amazing job to
really like take you on this journey and
so it was an awesome experience i loved
it
oh no that's awesome and it looks like
you're having fun out there doing it
which is always awesome and i'm
wondering too what went into the prep
for this character of melody knowing
this is based off of a podcast did you
go and listen to the podcast or did you
keep that separate i listened to the
podcast once when i was auditioning and
then once we started shooting i never
went back to it even though i loved it
and i thought it was awesome but the
even i really believe that the show
honors the podcast and keeps like
its essence um but then it takes off and
it's it's its own entire new thing and
melody's really different and
so i really tried to stay in the world
that was created for the show so i
didn't go back once we started shooting
oh that that makes sense and yeah i love
how you you made your own take on melody
and it was just exciting to see it
unfold as the season went on and what i
love about melody and you do so well is
the acting with the handheld camera so
when you're doing that is that
challenging especially the shots where
you're filming yourself like did you
have to get the right angle was that
something that you know was a different
challenge for you as an actress
what's funny is that i remember in
episode one um
becca thomas our director was like do
you know you keep filming yourself like
giving yourself a double chin she was
like maybe like lift it up i just like
didn't care i was like who gives a [ __ ]
like you know um
but i before i got to pittsburgh emailed
um
emailed the team and i was like i need
to have a high-end camera for myself so
i can
practice
and the minute i got there they gave me
my own one and i just
at home filmed myself as the character i
would just i always journal as a
character it's sort of how i get into
the headspace and so i just did these
video journals
as melody um and i never gave this
camera back i still have it because i
was like it'd be too embarrassing to
like give it back to them and have them
like watch all the stuff i did um and i
walked around pittsburgh and like filmed
some things and filmed myself and so i
tried to get as comfortable with it as
possible so that when i showed up on set
i'd spent some time with it already and
it didn't feel like an actor holding a
camera and it felt natural
yeah and it totally came off natural and
it's funny just talking to you right now
because i feel like you're going to
start interviewing me because i always
imagine melody interviewing the people
at the business yeah
but um you know it's interesting what
stood out to me about melody and your
portrayal of her was how likable she is
i mean like when i look at all the
protagonists and shows i've watched
recently she's so damn likable now
for you though did you find any bad or
like maybe some gray in melody in the
character
yeah i mean
i think being likable is tricky
um i think being a people pleaser
ultimately and just someone that cares
about
people as much as melody does
is her downfall essentially like she
can't help herself but go back and save
jess she she can't help but
care about people so deeply that you
know i think annabelle says like you
have to stop helping people so much it's
um
it's annoying and
i think that's a little bit of
foreshadowing for melody because you get
to the point where you're like oh wow
she really can't
stop herself and because she can't stop
herself she ends up actually hurting
herself
and i think that
that's a bit of a gray i think being too
likable being
too
pleasing to people can sometimes hurt
you
i've experienced that i've had to learn
the hard way like oh i i can't just be
nice to everyone i can't just i mean i
can i am naturally nice to everyone but
you have to be
discerning and i don't think melody is
very discerning
um
yeah maybe she becomes more discerning
at the show goes on and distress full of
people but she's
she's someone that will trust everyone
until proven otherwise
so running off of that you know that's
so interesting you're saying that
would dina do anything differently than
melody is there like one thing that
stands out to you like okay i would
definitely not do that in that situation
oh my god
there's so many similarities between me
and her that actually
doing it i was like yeah i feel like i'd
take all these same steps um even to the
point of her keeping the fact that she's
looking for her mother a secret that
she's not didn't tell her therapist
didn't tell her best friend
um
because she doesn't want to disappoint
people she doesn't want to upset anyone
she
but when i do anything different
maybe
i would once i saw
samuel down in that ritual
i would cut him out completely i
wouldn't give him any sort of like
maybe he's okay because he helped jess
and maybe there's she i'm like girl
don't
trust this guy
that would be i would be very
immediately distrustful of him after i
saw him you know down in
the room with all those people doing the
ritual for okay so
you bring up to the rituals
yeah people wondering watching that is
that ever spooky on set when you film
scenes like that is there ever something
in the air that's a little like i know
this is fake but you know do you feel
that ever yeah i was creeped out and i
started doing such weird scary dreams um
of like demons and like turning into a
demon and
it was just
it creeps up on you it especially
because
if you remember in that scene i'm alone
kind of behind a wall
in the dark hearing all this weird
breathing and
singing and
it creeped me out i got genuinely scared
i don't like being in the dark i don't
like
i get spooked really quickly so yes it
is really scary genuinely when you're
shooting so that that's good because
then it also helps with your character i
guess it's easy to get to that place you
don't really have to act you just yeah
allow it you're just freaked out yeah um
it's interesting too speaking of scary
scenes i think maybe my favorite scene
in the whole series is the dinner sean
scene um
yeah was that crazy filming in general
for you because like that would be
something i think even the performances
around you and your performance are you
like scared of where you guys are kind
of going in that like is it surreal
oh yeah i remember prepping knowing that
we had to shoot that scene that day and
thinking whoa this is gonna be
hard to shoot um
and saul the actress who plays beatrice
was so incredible it gives me chills she
never marked it she did it full out to
that level every single time and it was
horrifying to what because they really
did the effects on
the day
um like there was blood and everything
and it felt really real and it all of us
had really guttural reactions to it
um
oh yeah that that whole shooting that
whole thing was incredible and saul the
actress is
brilliant and she just gave her all like
take after take after she gave her take
i don't know how she did it it was
really impressive
no she was great memorable moments from
the show actually shooting that song 100
and and not just her performance with
your performance and everyone just like
being on the same page to pull that off
like you said it's so challenging
especially dinner scenes and adding that
so props to you guys amazing um
you also do something i think it's very
underappreciated is amazing screaming
and
i feel like especially
what really stood out to me is when the
guy fell off the building near you and
you screamed because the scream is what
scared me not the guy falling off the
building i was terrible it made me feel
terror which is awesome oh good oh
goodness
no is there any screaming compliment i'm
gonna take that and keep it thank you oh
no you deserve it and but is there is
there any scream queens you were
inspired by before this or just in your
life in general oh wow scream queens
that's a great question i wish i had an
immediate answer to it
but
i
i don't have someone in particular to
think of but i just love the idea that
scream queens is a thing i've always
found that knitting yeah
no but you tap into that really well
because there's some that can't pull
that off as much and it's so important
and i think i hope that means i'm a
scream queen that would be great
hell yeah i'm putting you in there you
want to get him
happy it's official uh breaking news
but um now speaking with dan the
character dan you and mama do have such
great chemistry together um but there is
going to be this debate people are
already having where you know how much
love is there maybe between melody and
dan and i'm talking about love love so
do you see any love love between melody
and dan or is it maybe kind of more of a
friendly
well that's what i love about what they
did is that it's ambiguous right it's
not the driving force is not this
romance between them but actually
something
deeper
um i had someone once say to me an
acting teacher this guy benjamin mathis
who's incredible out in l.a
that
human beings connect to each other
through their
pain
and
when you're connected he was talking
about with acting if you're trying to
connect like me dina to melody it's like
where do we
share pain right like where do we share
loss where are where our insecurities
this like reveal your insecurity to
someone and that's how you can connect
and i think with dan and melody i
thought about that throughout the show
because
they've both lost
their families they they're both orphans
essentially
um
you know melody has her um
you know adopted mother lila who just
recently died but they're searching for
meaning they're searching for identity
and so
that to me is
their primary connection is that they
share this like
sense of loss and sense of longing
um
and whether that turns romantic or
whether that turns platonic
doesn't matter because that is that is
so that has so much depth and it's so
true and i find that so moving and as
the arc with a man and a woman for that
to be the arc of the show that it's this
depth of connection that isn't about
expectation or outcome but actually
about true human
um
you know
true human heart
body soul
likeness that is beautiful to me
and that's a beautiful answer like see
that's why i ask those questions because
there's no one who can give it better
than you so really really good stuff and
that will kind of help the debate i
think on reddit and stuff about that
already i want there to be a debate on
reddit i hope oh there will be there
will be for sure but that will stir it
up which is good now
um you would mention that you know
melody is one of her driving forces
finding her mother this season and
it's amazing by the end of the season
she finds her mother so yeah can you
maybe predict maybe for season two like
how melody might process this
oh yeah i mean she was abandoned by her
i think she must
want some answers you know um
but i also think this really
shocking thing has happened where she's
suddenly been catapulted 25 years into
the future
and so
i just think that
such a great place to start season two
because
they now have to keep kaleigo in the
other world
will they do it they'll have to do it
together they have to find dan there are
all these different things that they
have to do and
there's hurt there's you know
a feeling of abandonment there's a
feeling of betrayal but there's also a
desperate need to have a mother to have
a connection with her that it's there's
so much there to i think get really
juicy and into
um so i'm really excited um
and i hope we get to do it because
to have a mother-daughter
duo like emotionally but also just as
um like a badass team trying to figure
all this out would be really incredible
yeah i hope you guys get to do it too
i'm sure you will uh everybody's so
excited here even watching this
interview seeing your great performance
are probably so just happy to see this
amazing actress you're breaking out
which is awesome uh
dina thank you so much for joining me
today and everybody please make sure to
re-watch archive 81 and netflix tell
your friends about it let's get this
show going it's so good uh dina thank
you so much for joining me today i hope
to talk to you in the future steve it
was a pleasure thank you so much